yeah that's right Emily so you know a
hallmark of the apple event is when
steve jobs at the end of the event would
announce one more thing behind him a
giant Ski would appear dark screen with
white letters saying one more thing Tim
Cook has asked you that issue that in
recent product announcements but this
time sure enough one more thing is
indeed the Apple watch a wearable device
we know they've been working on for
years they've had at least 150 people
there Cooper nearby Cupertino
headquarters working on this wearable
device details of which are being
announced just now back with us Paul
kujawski our bloomer contributing editor
from San Diego as well as Wired's deputy
editor joe brown with me here in the
studio and keith raboy of khosla
ventures we were watching Apple play
luxurious music as it unveiled this
watch with a rectangular face a
SmartWatch that doesn't actually look
like a watch Joe first thoughts I really
wanted to not want that thing but it
looks really hot from the sort of
swappable bands that magnetic latch on
the strap I mean from I have always said
I will not wear a wearable I wear a real
watch I'm gonna try and stick to that
line as long as I can but i think is
definitely pretty good okay so this
passes the acid test to me do the real
question for a product like this is if
it had no functionality whatsoever would
you wear it and this clearly passes that
test multiple bands that can be swapped
in and out Paul are you gonna wear this
thing no I mean I'm still not there yet
oh yeah these are all love yeah but you
know I still I still don't get over the
hurdle of you know what is it what is it
what does it do for me that I want to go
backwards in time and take a device
whose functionality has fundamentally
been absorbed by a general-purpose
device a cell phone and go back and say
you know what I want that back on my
wrist again I'm not there let's talk
about this Apple here we are is
redesigning a product that has existed
for hundreds of years what's up their
loot the brand and all no let's take a
step back and talk about what a watch's
right it's for men one of the only
permissible forms of jewelry and that's
a big market and more men wear watches
than women yes that's true and fewer men
wear wearables than women so I had
originally come into this thinking okay
they're gonna aim this squarely at women
because women actually wear wearable
devices but this is a complete opposite
take it's actually trying to get men who
are who will categorize themselves as
watch guys from what I've seen so far to
wear something that is more form than
function case why would you wear this
well i was looking well first of all it
just looks beautiful and so absolutely
the aesthetics are incredibly appealing
secondly a device like a phone is not
very good for active sports so for
example if you play basketball or soccer
you can't have your phone on you so if
you're going to track and measure
yourself you're going to have this
fitness and health orientation you need
something that's capable be aware now
this look pretty metallics I don't know
I'm gonna get away with this in my
soccer league they have to tape it up or
something no I'm incredibly compelled by
it Paul we know that Apple has almost
never been first to market they didn't
have the first computer or the first
smartphone or the first tablet it and
now we have them redesigning a
hundred-year-old product does that
matter no I think it has all the
hallmarks you can see the obvious appeal
right has all the hallmarks of a
category that apple would like to
reinvent you know there was a long time
we talked about Apple reinventing
television for all the same reasons i'll
be at not a hundred-year-old category
but a category that looked like it
become completely stale and lacking
innovation and people getting wrapped up
in all the wrong sorts of functionality
and so the watch has all of those
characteristics and so you can see why
that makes sense to apple I still fall
back in my original point though having
sent all of those things it also is a
device that looks like much of its most
important functionality has been pulled
into other devices with the exception of
some very interesting health and fitness
edge cases that do not to my mind
anyways represent the kind of market
that's really going to add materially to
apples bottom line okay so it looks nice
yep you guys have agreed but is it going
to change the way we behave are we going
to answer calls on this check messages
are we gonna use this to track all of
these different things about our body I
think what Paul said is really accurate
i mean this relies upon an ecosystem
more than sort of acting as a standalone
device you have a bunch of apps would
already exist that this can play with
and that's a really nice
you ad will it change apples business I
mean I think probably the answer is no
given that you probably could add a
business the size of jawbone they could
and and it still wouldn't change Apple
well this is so Tim Cook's first new
product under you know Apple under tim
cook Keith do you see them could they
create a big I mean a lot of people wear
watches I actually think this could be
massive because it basically unlocks new
value proposition so this is as the
phone becomes a replacement for your
desktop because that's what basically
this new phablet in landscape mode is
going to do is you're going to do all
your email and all your work in that in
this mode this is basically the new
phone so the smallest or iPod or iPhone
you know it's the smallest device that
allows you to be functional all the time
you're gonna wear your watch 24 hours a
day so it's always with you Corey
Johnson do you want to wear this will
you also use it uh I don't know I mean
you know I'm pretty festoon with my
gadgets as it is i mean i know you know
i think what's interesting art yeah
right so I regularly wear a heart rate
monitor on my wrist from me oh I've got
my jawbone up the monitor is sort of my
my exercise at least some exercise
activity and that's the right thing for
me one wonders if Apple might be looking
at smaller use cases for products that
aren't such global devices that
everyone's going to want to have them to
some level the smartphone's already that
right certainly the tablet is it's only
for the most wealthy people in the
society in the global society that's a
big market I think that when apple looks
at this though you know I that brings to
mind i mentioned i saw dr. oz here
earlier and some health care companies
around as well that that they look at
this not just as a way to tell time and
as a way to make phone calls but as a
way to participate in in this growing
market of monitoring health in all forms
not just the extreme exercises you know
people like Paul and I trudging around
and bikes and running long distances as
I want but people monitoring their
health in a society and with
technologies that can help provide
information to their medical
professionals so that the technology is
much more incorporated into their life
with their phone with their tablet and
yes with this wearable now I now that we
know that the watch
indeed been unveiled we don't know yet
how much it's going to cost Paul a
question I asked earlier but now that we
know that this thing is happening why do
you need a watch if you have a phone
that's that good so I think the argument
I'm kind of you know making it and
making this up as I go along so feel
free to stop me but I mean so why my
argument would be that Apple sees how it
consumers are steadily moving to larger
and larger devices and these larger and
larger phones are increasingly becoming
in a cumbersome even if they thinner and
they're curved and everything else so
there's now by that sort of migration up
market in terms of form factors is
increasingly a hole at the bottom of the
market that used to be where you had
flip phones and smaller devices for
making calls and doing texting and
whatever else and as well as all of
these other health and fitness apps so
that in a sense they're creating a hole
in the market by consumer behavior
moving up market and so you know there's
your argument for why you might have
something like this to your wrist it's
because phones have gotten so damn big
what companies out there should be
worried Keith I mean you guys are
investing in companies that are trying
to a develop for these devices or maybe
make watches of their own I wouldn't I
don't think any company should be
worried I think every company should you
know quarterback their own strategy and
executed with a different value
proposition that's compelling for their
users but I think this product is going
to be attractive and maybe like the
Google Android world should be worried
because now they're going to sink
together your iPad your laptop your Mac
your phone and your device and so
there's going to be an incredible
ecosystem and you're going to feel naked
if some of the communications and some
of the data doesn't go from place point
one the point to two point three point
four and if Apple's really paying
attention actually you'll feel really
bad and naked if your friends aren't on
the same ecosystem and so if they get
that right then it doesn't matter what
Android does